and some with last week's video on the
Infinity Gauntlet and Infinity stones
being well-received I figured I'd test
the waters a second time by focusing on
the first 10 Iron Man armors and Marvel
Comics and this is really just designed
to see whether or not people are
interested in seeing something like this
but something I'd also like to point out
here is that like our video on the
Infinity Gauntlet we're only going to be
focusing on the versions of these armors
from the main Marvel Universe so in my
video on Ironman explained we had run
over the first armor which was presented
as a kind of bare-bones suit using a
combination of basic parts and on hand
medals and truth' there's really not
much to offer here in the way of
discussion except to say that it was
really only designed as a temporary suit
with Tony intended to create something
more advanced later on now this more
advanced suit came in the form of the
mark 2 armor with tales of suspense
issue number 48 now I'm actually going
to give this armor a little more
attention than the others and the reason
why is because the advent of the mark ii
actually set the stage for the rest of
his armor models going throughout iron
man's publications and marvel comics
with that in mind this armor actually
came out of marvel moving forward with
the Iron Man series after considering it
to be a success within the comics
however this armor came out of Tony
Stark doing battle with a villain named
Nathan Dali who at the time of this
story was able to create voodoo dolls of
victims and force him to act in
accordance with his own wishes with the
first conflict between the two seeing
Iron Man's defeat this also came with
Starks realization that the mark 1 armor
was simply too large and cumbersome
being equivalent to a broadsword rather
than a scalpel going back to the drawing
board
start designed a new set of armor
composed of a metal alloy that was
thinner and more flexible than the mark
1 armor but also just as strong with the
mark 1 draw a massive amounts of power
from the miniature battery and Starks
chest the new armor was designed to draw
less power and more efficiently utilize
the power that it did draw as it was
described as the main chess piece
contained a brunt of the armors
durability due to starch need to ensure
that the battery in his heart wasn't
damaged however redundancies were put in
place with the wristbands containing
backup batteries should the main battery
fail allowing start to remain alive and
operable running along the arms and legs
was a yellow metal alloy that was more
akin to fabric in terms of his
appearance and function but was highly
durable and connected the risk to the
shoulders using mag
it's some to also take note of is that
the mark 2 did not have repulsor rays in
the hands and instead relied on the
enhanced strength and durability
provided by the suit as well as magnetic
and electric repulsors in addition to
jets on the feet finally the last
upgrade offered by the mark 2 armor over
the mark 1 was the helmet well the mark
1 was a giant head of sorts that was
soldered onto the body and limited
starks field of view the more - helmet
operated more akin to a human head
allowing for turning and better fields
of vision as well as an adjustable face
plate having said that the repulsor rays
of Iron Man made their debut in 1965
with tales of suspense issue number 66
and the introduction of the mark 3 on
its surface with the exception of a nose
being built into the facemask as well as
the repulsor rays the physical
difference between the mark 2 and the
mark 3 weren't that big however the true
difference between the two came with
regards to the upgrades to the suits
offensive and defensive capabilities
with a mark 1 and mark 2 provided for
magnetic and electric repulsors in the
hands as well as Jets in the feet and
enhanced strength the mark 2 also
offered varying sensors to detect
movement and life signs a hidden blade
first aid and EMP and the ability to
withstand atomic explosions at close
range
the mark 3 armor improved on all these
elements of the mark 2 by upgrading the
electric and magnetic repulsors to
repulsor rays capable of emitting
particle energies weakened enough to
push an opponent away to being strong
enough to burn holes through all metals
with the exception of adamantium and
vibranium the mark 3 armor was also able
to emit Holograms and heat absorb
extreme temperatures and contained smoke
bombs bomb pellets a chemical kit a
cutting blade a sound duplicator and a
high frequency wave generator to deafen
opponents now moving on to the mark 4
this armor debuted an Ironman issue
number 65 in 1976 coming out of the
destruction of the mark 3 armor during a
story which saw happy Hogan becoming a
villain named free the mark 4 was
designed to improve on the mark 3 by
removing obsolete features and upgrading
existing ones to this end the mark 4
used 3d knitting technology meaning that
while the yellow sleeves and legs were
still fabric in appearance and composed
of a metal alloy a force field was
utilized to give the appearance that the
arms and legs were solid metal
furthermore rather than simply absorbing
extreme temperatures and dispersing them
the mark 4 was able to absorb any
of energy that wasn't psionic in nature
store it and use it to power the armor
with a mark 4 also used a uni-beam which
is identical to the repulsor rays but
discharge from the chest it also had the
ability to evade detection emit multiple
Holograms rather than just one distorts
large voice to keep his identity hidden
burrow underground control the marks one
two and three and adjust the visual
spectrum of the armor to infrared and
constantly monitor the life signs of
various members of the Avengers and
Starks closest friends regardless of the
locations or distance from him what I
also like to mention is that one of this
armors biggest benefits came with the
fact that an Iron Man issued over 19 in
1969 stark underwent heart transplant
surgery which removed the issue of the
shrapnel potentially killing him what
this meant was at the mark for in all
future models could be designed for
maximum efficiency without having to
worry about special attention being paid
to starts heart now moving to the mark 5
this version debuted an Iron Man issue
number 142 and is the first armor start
to be used for exotic purposes like
traveling into space while this doesn't
mean that the previous versions were
incapable of space travel the mark 5 was
designed explicitly for this purpose
meaning it could stay in space longer as
a result the armor only appears about 15
times the Marvel Comics and aside from
an improved life-support system control
system auto camera and sonar there isn't
much difference between this and the
mark for jumping to the March 6 like the
mark 5 this version was designed to
function in a limited capacity and that
it was designed for use underwater
however the armor contained a few
abilities that were exotic including the
ability to eject ink similar to an
octopus emit an electric pulse similar
to an eel and contained turbines in the
boots rather than energy based Jets in
addition to this because it was designed
to allow Stark to visit Namor in his
home city of Atlantis the armor was
reinforced and capable and withstanding
the pressure of the ocean at extremely
low depths continuing on with these
exotic armors the mark 7 was designed to
function with stealth taking presidents
above all else to this end the armor was
black in nature rather than the
signature red in yellow in terms of his
abilities this armor was capable of
absorbing sonar waves making it
invisible to radar containing dampening
units on the boots to minimize the noise
and emissions of the Jets make a
camouflage to its environment but only
using singular colors
rather than a multitude of different
forms and shapes now the mark 8 returns
us to the very standards of Iron Man's
armor z' and where it was originally
introduced an Iron Man issue number 200
1985 the mark 8 gained its fame during
the six-part story armored Wars taking
place between Iron Man issues 225 and
231 when it initially appeared because
it was designed to be used by James
Rhodes the mark 8 was for all intents
and purposes identical to the mark 4
however with armor war Singh Stark's
Iron Man technology stolen and sold to
varying criminals the mark 8 was
upgraded with vast enhancements designed
to combat the various criminals who had
created their own versions of the Iron
Man armor to this end at the height of
its abilities the market had improved
flight and maneuverability with the
booster pack on its back to allow for
faster flight the repulsor rays and the
unibeam were much stronger capable of
inflicting incredible damage on
virtually all metals except for
adamantium and vibranium melee weapons
like heat Lance's cutting lasers shock
sticks and tractor beams were added for
close range battles and a disruptor was
added allowing for the armor to Jam
electrical signals that transitioning to
the mark 9 this model began the line of
stark signature design in terms of its
physical appearance and was a massive
step up in terms of power and
capabilities because the armor wars
revealed the fact that the world had the
ability to duplicate Starks technology
as a plans were now out in the open
much like all-new all-different
invincible Iron Man start went back to
the drawing board regarding the design
of his suits while the mark 9 had been
an experiment prior to armor Wars rather
than keeping it locked away Stark
revisited the sued and added a number of
upgrades
first and foremost where all the
previous models used batteries or relied
on stored energy for power the marker
nine used beta particles now to be
honest I can't think of a way to
describe beta particles without going
into a long-winded explanation about
ionizing radiation and electrons so to
keep it simple the armor basically uses
solar energy from the Sun in a more
efficient way being that it was faster
and capable of stronger repulsor rays
than his previous models in addition to
this as a byproduct of the armor Wars
and in order to ensure that the future
forms of his armor could not be copied
start installed an electronic chip which
would automatically shut the armor down
if anyone used it without authorization
keeping it from being tampered with or
duplicated
building on the technologies of the
previous mark armors the mark 9 was also
able to tap into electrical interfaces
track up to 60 targets at once
regardless of their size location or
distance translate all known languages
in the Marvel Universe automatically
engage safety protocols a kept start
from going blind and deaf while in
battle
I met various gases ranging from
incapacitating agents to deadly toxins
as well as physical modifications
allowing the armor to travel into the
depths of space and down to the deepest
parts of the ocean now as a last armored
in this video the mark 10 came as a
byproduct of an event called Operation
galactic storm and was the first armor
designed explicitly to stand toe-to-toe
with advanced alien technology as a 19
part series written in 1992 operation
galactic storm saw most of Earth's major
heroes including the Avengers Avengers
West Coast Hank Pym Thor quasar Captain
America and Iron Man coming together in
an effort to end the war between the
Shiar and the create now if you're
interested in learning about these races
I have videos on them but the overall
theme was at the Kree spiritual leader
called the supreme intelligence had
launched a war against the Shiar in
their hopes that they would be able to
use a weapon called the bomb which
would annihilate 99% of the Kree
population forcing its race to evolve
with the intention proving to be true
because Tony Stark was going headlong
into the conflict rather than staving
off occasional invasions the Iron Man
armor needed to be modified to cope with
the advanced technologies of both decree
and the Shiar to this end because a mark
9 was so advanced there weren't a lot of
changes to be made here the first
upgrade came in the form of a cloaking
device that could hide the armor from
the radars above the Kree and the Shiar
as well as an advanced onboard computer
that could calculate virtually any
scenario and its outcome in addition to
this the life-support systems were
modified to keep a detailed analysis of
Starks vital systems the helmet was
designed to protect from psionic attack
from powerful individuals like the
supreme intelligence and oracle a member
of the Shiar imperial guard capable of
telepathy and finally the armor was
fitted with a self-destruct mechanism
capable of obliterating virtually any
vessel in the universe without being
sent we're going to bring this video to
an end and let me know how you guys
think the armor in the comics compares
to the armors and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I'm kind of curious what you
all think about that
and I will catch you guys later please